[Music]
hello there
fortnight pushed another update today
and as i missed last week's
i thought we should catch up right now
there's been updates to the law there's
been updates to the story and there's
just been some
random updates but it's worth it so sit
your butt down for five minutes and
let's break down
all the new story and map updates in
week four and five of fortnite chapter
two
season seven and yeah we're gonna talk
about the bromance
this week you'll first notice the change
to the lobby screen
gone has the summer backdrop and the
central hole in the island is back
in the background but there's a
difference this screen now has parasites
alongside us
these weren't here two weeks ago which
feeds into the main update of the week
holly hedges has been overrun the small
town is now the home
of the alien hordes who have been
renovating a huge anti-gravity blockage
is in place
and within that is the alien homeworld's
biome
their funky purple trees stand tall and
one is so strong it lifted a forklift
off the ground
around this place are lots of things i
do not understand in the slightest
from these seats i think to lighting to
these
any ideas what our alien overlords are
hoping to achieve here
the key focus seems to be cat food we
know that they love it like we said in
the last update the aliens are addicted
to cat food
and i'm sure you've spotted the
replicants out in the world pretending
to be one of us
hiding in plain sight by the way i found
one during a game of one shot
and here's a pro tip kill them and take
their weapon
it's crazy open one shot and makes you
feel like a real hacker man's
montage please
yes he can foot nice
over at the beach marks the end of our
alien summer
the believers are leaving and slowly
things are returning to normal the
artwork is washing away the decorations
are falling down
rubbish is strewn around the streets and
the stage
has left us rip the summer the io troops
remain in this location
continuing their study of the drop ships
and analyzing those alien beings trying
to locate the aliens and muggers
guess we check back next week
[Music]
okay let's talk about the boys the
aliens brought back
many old locations in fortnite but the
greatest thing of all
was this duo they returned to us bill
and ted
former enemies now brothers in arms last
week the two escaped the alien ship and
hid out in their new home
at the very south of the island i
monitored them
and it's adorable ted makes chimichangas
while bill looks out over the ocean
contemplating life when the two meet up
they exchange random emotes
but then bill tells him he loves him
what a bromance
this week the two are catching a movie
together up at risky reels
they walk around enjoying the new world
especially the little kiddie play area
for some reason
before bill desperately needs the loo he
legit goes to the toilet
while his bro plays with a rubik's cube
next the duo visit the fire pit
for some marshmallows before sharing a
joke
they spend their cash on food and drink
have a boogie
share some skills and genuinely just
love life again
i hope they move again next week so
thank you for bringing them back epic
much appreciated everyone needs a little
positivity in their life
other things of note the shadow of the
mother ship seems to be moving each and
every day
the general theory is that it will stop
over the coral castle location next
tuesday and that location will be
changed completely
the shadow right now backs this theory
up oh there is an easter egg that i keep
forgetting to talk about so let's do
that right now it's pretty cool
and can be found at spawn island look
around enough and you will find
this room with a filing cabinet behind a
cordon
this rang a bell to me and i so happen
to be playing the game control
a game all about the laws of reality
being broken
it's a great game by the way you should
definitely play it it is said that
random items in our world can be
objects of power completely random
everyday items like a
rubber duck or a filing cabinet in this
case
each holding a different power set for
example there is a fridge in control
which must be watched
yes you heard me right a refrigerator
someone's job is to watch it constantly
this object of power is set up in the
same way in fortnite right now
i know it's only an easter egg but this
actually ties into the law
in the game the moment the player turns
its back on the fridge
it eats a man alive we are then sent
into another reality to battle it
it's it's really weird but it's really
good so i'm going to keep an eye on this
filing cabinet just in case it could be
more important than we know
right this is a shorter episode than
usual because i'm going straight back to
making the batman fortnite zero
point final issue and wow there is a lot
of lore in that that should be up
tomorrow maybe earlier if i'm feeling
funky
here's a bunch of legends thank you so
much for using code adamaru i really
appreciate it
and i will see you later for more
fortnite content
[Music]
[Applause]